Okay,
should be live here.
And go set the title on Twitch and I'll
switch the um this screen over
I don't know why you can't just set the
default category,
but whatever. There you go.
open reream just so I can ban people if
needed
and
we're good.
How's it going folks?
Little bit of a late start today.
Algorithm has been dragging on me a
little bit, you know. Um, I'm really not
enjoying this whole bullshitty codeex
workflow. I really want to get back to
writing real code. Um,
but there are a couple things that I
just haven't been able to figure out
with the algorithm yet.
So,
I'm concerned now that it's like
it's grown so massively that it could
just be dumb bugs, right?
It could literally just be some dumb
bugs. Um, I think what I'm going to try
to do is I'm going to get it stable. I'm
going to get the like plus one piece of
domain knowledge working well. And then
I think I'm just going to push
everything and we're going to minify.
At least one round of minifying
that.
Hey Kvery. Um, I don't know if you saw
the post about the trailer thing. I
don't know if you want to go anything on
that, but that's definitely a cool end.
There's like a post on X about like
backing up double like multiple
trailers.
Uh, what the [ __ ]
I'd stopped at two.
I mean, two is already cool, isn't it?
Probably three would just work now,
honestly.
What are we cooking today? We're still
stuck on the algorithm. I'm starting to
get a little bit irritated with it as
well.
Hey, Cash renderer so I can run in a web
browser. Wait, a render? A Majoko
renderer?
Wait, just use Rayb man. Rayb compiles
to wasome,
right?
Just do state into Rayb and you're good.
So is better than [ __ ]
I call [ __ ]
I'm also How long was this? Like how
long ago was this thing started?
Two years means it's probably not
complete vibe coded crap. But what is
this
samples?
Where's source?
Where's 2D?
Well, I call [ __ ] either way because
Rayb is like literally the single best
library I've worked with.
So
click on one.
I mean, they don't have like full
samples. These are just like basically
miniature 3D things.
Is this just rapping?
This is just wrapping. I am gooey.
I don't believe it. Simply just like I'm
not seeing anything immediately. And Ray
is like literally the best software
I've uh been able to work with.
Like, I've honestly learned so much from
the way that that thing is built.
GL cross compat layer very low level.
That's what Ray does. Did you try Fable?
No, we're not doing like the every new
model [ __ ] thing. [ __ ] that.
Uh, are we at 11?
Oh, hang on. Did this actually help?
Are we stuck? No, we're still stuck.
Yeah, I mean I did constellation with
Ray Gooey and it was very nice.
Like that library is basically put
together in the best possible way with
the best possible docs. It like
Unstable. Interesting.
Really unstable or only a little
unstable?
Only a little unstable. Okay.
I I'm not listening to anything
Anthropic says anymore.
texture values
optimized for updating the actual
allow you to set the texture type
rendering for example I've done that
before I'm pretty sure
uh I'm trying to remember I think I've
done that somewhere and I'm trying to
remember where I've done that. I did
that in um
was it a texture that I loaded it into
or did I write a shader? I think I might
have just written a shader for it. I'm
thinking about the terraform env. I
thought I did it for that. I know I've
done that for something though.
Really? I don't have any intuition on
rewards.
The reward that you sent me in dev.
structuring. Currently do a delta. Oh,
it's for the planet.
Neutrals don't count.
Well, what's the actual objective of um
Can you not just train it on winds?
Like how long are the episodes
wipe out entirely? Have you tried just
training it on winds first?
Episode is way longer.
Well, you said it's
What do you mean multilaunch? You said
it's by 500 turns.
What's that mean?
Oh, because of the way you have the
action space.
I mean, it's probably more so like
entity encoding for obs and stuff is
probably the bigger issue. All right,
let me see what happened here. It's
stuck on L12.
This is better though, right? This was
12. Oh, I can't tell. Great. Lovely.
Uh, I think this is better.
What did I do for state buffer? State
buffer is tiny.
Yeah, Jess, you might need to use the
point encoder
cuz it like that sounds like a very
entityheavy type of environment.
Algo's very irritating. Um, I'm
narrowing in on stuff. I think I'm going
to what I'm going to do is I'm going to
add the one piece of domain knowledge
back in. See if we can full solve and
then that's going to and then I'm going
to try to like minify the code base
because it's just gotten out of hand.
Or Spencer asks me if I've gotten any
XDMs
based on all the new things. And I
haven't checked.
Sorry, one sec, guys. I'm just
responding to a couple DMs.
profile. Hang on.
Oh, there's Tasha. Okay.
All right, that's everything. Cool. back
to uh back to dev
overview of what you're doing right now.
Some people can find out easily. How am
I supposed to provide an overview of
what I'm doing when I don't really know
what I'm doing and it changes every 30
minutes.
Like I'm fixing the crazy algorithm
mostly.
Um, I'm trying to figure out why the new
state set algorithm isn't working as
expected and I'm triaging a bunch of
different potential explanations for
Okay, we'll try this since you're all
insistent.
Can I get text?
text.
Okay.
Uh a blading
date
that face
them
type for 5.0
Otherwise, I have to update the title on
three platforms.
it. The next time I get one, I'll add
the stupid fable equals banner.
Whatever.
It's actually the one thing I really
hate about streaming is like I really
like not being in the middle of SF where
you can't think state straight because
it's just LM horseshit constantly. Um,
but very much does annoy me when I have
to deal with it on just stream while I'm
trying to do other stuff.
it's honestly the cigarette sales
industry at this point. Like it's awful.
Like I really no longer like my field as
a whole at all. Or rather, I suppose to
say I reject that I'm in the same field
anymore.
Like, it's just marketing disguised as
tech.
Okay,
that's good. Nice progress. Um, as you
can probably tell, I've gotten sort of
stuck on um the algorithm a little bit.
It's really annoying, man. There's like
one last piece of domain knowledge I
like I can't full solve without. Um
the diff has also just gotten really
big. So I'm going to try to like I'm
basically going to try to get it to the
point where I can turn on turn off that
one piece of domain knowledge and see
the consistent full solves with it and
um
and then clean up the code base to be
minimal from there. So we can like
actually start going through and seeing
for possible error sources
specific domain knowledge. So the thing
that's happening right now is using
advantage to admit segments is too
noisy. So what happens is that you end
up kicking out the segments that you
want or you end up not admitting the
good segments because you just have some
noisy weird high advantage segments from
fully solved levels.
It's very annoying.
Yeah, but I think most likely it's going
to be um
just fully fully finish this. We'll have
um we'll point codeex at the 40 branch
versus this. We'll get the diff minimize
so I can actually manually review
because there's just a bunch of crap in
there now.
and then and then we'll figure from
there.
So, if this solves, at least we know the
domain knowledge works. And if not, then
we've probably just broken something
along the way.
We also could just run some sweeps. I
could do hyper pram sweeps without
including the network size. That might
be okay. Um,
yeah, it's annoying.
invalidate all your research. No,
usually I don't get that, man. Um, I'm
pretty careful with that. Normally what
I end up getting is I get bugs that like
make it do worse than expected. So it
ends up actually being like a lower
bound on what we have.
like the algorithm is pretty clear and
simple at this point and um it's in my
mind there's not really any question
that state sets are going to be powerful
and have to go into the algorithm. It's
really just a question of the form.
Yeah, I know. They're awful.
And like, okay, here's the thing, right?
I could be I could prototype this myself
in Torch just about as fast as the model
can, but then the runs are way slower.
And actually, Torch's numeric are bad
because Torch itself is vibe coded dog
[ __ ] So,
I mean, ultimately, I guess the correct
thing to be to do would just be to like
have your low-level library be minified
as possible and nice and easy to work
with. And we're getting towards that,
but it's very very difficult when like
literally there's not a single piece of
surrounding anything we can use other
than Rayb for viz because just
everything is just vibecoded crap these
This
Okay. So, we did have terminals in here
before.
Okay. No, it's not stuck. It took a
while, but it's not stuck.
Yeah, that's more consistent.
Well, that does tell you that it can
actually take a little while to latch,
though, right?
And then what? I guess we should maybe
try
viewer CLMs.
All right, Mike is back.
Man,
stupid Windows. This is why it's like
I haven't wanted to bother reinstalling
this box.
Like, how stupid is it that like just
the thing screwing up and not
recognizing your camera crashes your
entire display?
Like how dumb is that?
Still haven't gotten the 14 solve.
That's a little concerning, isn't it?
Well, that might be a good thing
actually if we have some other thing
that's screwy. Oh, 14. There's 14.
14. Latch quick.
It should because it should definitely
be in the buffer now, right? There's no
question that we have the correct data
in the buffer.
I actually have to try a couple things
now, don't I?
This is this is actually good news.
Okay, this is good news because this
means that there are some additional
we know that this approach can solve,
but then there just some additional
small details that affect it
that should also affect the other one.
And we actually don't latch 14. Okay,
that's a modest difference.
So if we do like this and
You don't need to step reality fast.
It's like so incredibly ingrained at
this point that everybody thinks, "Oh,
we need accurate sim." You don't need
accurate sim. Need good enough SIM
that's Fast.
It's cool that somebody just got five
instantly.
Native policy
Wait, what is the uh what's that UI that
he's gotten?
This is the puffer one, isn't it?
All right, that's all. Nothing else.
Uh, what do we got?
Oh, wait, wait. What's this? Uh,
corridor.
M maybe I don't know if that's a hard
game.
Longer is easier
to think where LM hacked the end result.
Well, obviously that's not what's going
to happen here, man.
Like I'm not just like the thing is the
eval is not even the end of that I'm
training on, right? Like we're going to
use the same We're going to use the
exact same code on other ends that have
not been touched.
No, I've played corridor chess. I
understand. But I don't understand the
strategy space. You see the difference?
Like I don't understand how complex the
high end of that is.
Interesting. Are we stuck at 13 still?
Well, this would be nice logs if we um
Oh, wait. We aren't failing to latch.
We're failing to discover. It's even
weirder, isn't it?
Why are we failing to discover?
Oh, well, the policy is super unstable,
which is not great.
with one quarter of the data from CL?
That doesn't seem right to me.
Skills with board size. I don't know if
there is a complex like
it may or may not. Okay. Okay. Yeah,
this is super unstable.
Have you tried Claude? All right, we're
we're adding the [ __ ] message to this
screen with one grace period for that
one.
This is actually correct latching
behavior.
This could actually just be hypers to be
fair. This could actually just be
hypers. Um,
what if I sweep it a little bit on this?
I just don't like to It's like I get
asked constantly about like this model
versus that model versus whatever and it
really really doesn't matter for what
I'm doing.
like the focus here is on this is like
core reinforcement learning development.
Um, currently we're coming up with a
pretty cool new algorithm
and like the model stuff just doesn't
matter.
I think what we're going to do is we're
going to just like get this stable.
We're going to commit this and then
we're going to minimize because it's a
freaking mess right now. And um we're
probably going to sweep from there. like
a small sweep
because I think what's happening is like
I've done most of this stuff somehow
without even having like decent hypers
and it's starting to bite us
because like even the Oracle here which
you can see it's actually doing fine
latching
it's just not getting the last couple
segments like the last couple levels
because the score crashes
that's all that's happening.
Yeah, if this is not working because
it's in unstable,
we're probably
I wouldn't be surprised that that is
also the advantage spikes as well. We're
probably whatever is going wrong here is
just being exacerbated when we're using
advantage to admit segments.
Um
it's going to have to be a restricted
param sweep though, right? Like we're
going to have to intentionally keep the
model small
and also prevent it from cranking replay
ratio and stuff.
let this go and then we'll do the
commit.
I will say that aside from the
stability,
even with whatever the hell hypers we
have here,
Let's see.
A little harder on 10.
Okay, maybe not.
But this one, absolutely, it should be
fine, right?
Like latching 10 should just work.
That's a little sketchy actually if it
doesn't.
But that will be very nice for logs
because this this one 100% should work
and any failures here we have to be
correct. Okay, I'm seeing the way
forward. It's annoying but I'm seeing
the way forward.
See, it does eventually latch though,
right?
It can take a while here, but the thing
is because of the um the scorebased
metric, we're essentially guaranteed
that we have a quarter of the data being
from the solve segment until it actually
gets solved.
So that kind of just guarantees that you
will eventually latch. And everything
else is just like sampling details, etc.
just prevent you from taking too long to
do it. But you should never get stuck.
Did you do Sim to real for robotics? Um,
so Finn and Sam have a little bit of
stuff on drones
and then there's also been some stuff
with Puffer going on to at least toy
cars that I know of. I think that um
people are trying to get it onto real
cars.
Uh
the robot uh the drone stuff we'll
probably still be doing over the summer
depending on what Finn wants to do. He's
joining us for an internship. Aside from
that though, robotics really is not our
main area. We do sim to sim that we do
quite often. Um,
but yeah, for robotics specifically, for
it to be worth it for us to build out
more stuff there, we'd have to have a a
major client really want something like
that in Puffer
because for our own internal research,
like having control ends doesn't
particularly help us more than what we
have now.
And um you know it's a top area of
application but it's not the only top
area of application.
MCU that was cool convert. Yeah that's
fun. I really don't think that like so
honestly for systems that have a low
number of degrees of freedom simil just
not that hard.
Okay, this gets level 14
and I think this might even get 15. And
it's just like numerical instability
getting DT to match.
Yeah. And this is like Kvert. If I were
telling you how to do this, I would tell
you to account for the DT stuff and to
randomize.
Uh, so there's the instability, right?
So, we get 14 and it's just perfectly
fine. And then we're not going to get
the lucky 15
if uh the score is just crashing
unstable.
And that's got to just be hypers dr with
DT.
Did you make it observable? And is it
observable in the real system?
There's more that you can do there.
That's something I've dealt with before.
Yeah. So, what I would do is um you
know, I would I would vary the amount of
time between steps and I would make the
time since last step observable because
you can get that on the microcontroller
as well. That would handle variance.
Now, there's basic stuff like this that
you can do that makes quite a big
difference and it's very easy to test.
You know, you can even convert you can
literally even test the transfer without
going to the real robot, right? You can
basically just make the held out version
of your sim where DT is different or it
varies differently and you can see if it
crashes like it crashes your PF. There
are a lot of things you can do for this.
Okay, so now at least we know what
happens.
What are you working on today? Hey
Robin, we're working on the new state
setbased algorithm. It's kind of a mess.
It's like close, but there's some
screwiness.
Oh, where's the tab?
What's What's the mode thing? mode.
What's the like the annoying plan mode
thing?
Are you doing no code, Deb? Abso
fuckingutely not.
This is anything but.
In fact, what I'm doing now is get rid
of all the shitty LLM changes so I can
edit the thing manually and actually
make sense of it.
I honestly once I have the next core
algorithm bits in um I think I'm going
to be able to take a step back from all
the crazy
science stuff that I've had to do with
this. Well,
I really at some point I want to take
the time to get the kernels as small and
simple as possible.
It's a little annoying because the thing
is the algorithm is still in
development, right?
And like good parts of it are stable,
but there's still quite a bit of stuff
we need to figure out.
I think state sets is the biggest piece
of it though, frankly. and state set
simplifies a lot. Like we were actually
able to make a lot of the environment
side stuff um easier with this
special puffer lib to be in the
simulation department.
I mean we do um we do professional
simulation development. That is our core
thing that we sell.
How much you have to create outside of
following Nvidia CUDA library? So,
puffer is implemented in CUDA C. Um, we
use KU blast for matt moles.
We have a couple other small bits that
we use, but that's it. Oh yeah, NCCL for
comms.
I mean, but pretty much everything has
to be implemented from the ground up.
Like obviously CUDA is a given. We're
not going to implement our own
like what like we're not going to
implement it in like the assembly or
write our own version of CUDA.
I think we can put it it can just go
into a separate file because it'll be
easier to track
of hook.
Yep.
You can read the puffer four source. The
hover for source is quite clean.
There is some stuff upcoming eventually
where like at some point it is possible
that we will have to accept some more um
Nvidia library usage because
well really depends how big our models
get. Um, if our model's got to be
several hundred million parameters for
instance at any point for any reason,
then at that point you kind of have to
use
um some of the higher level libraries
and not like
it's mostly that you need the stuff that
automatically like sets up Matt Moles
for you on the specific chip that you're
running at that point.
We have one little bit of a messy thing
here.
So, the point of this um is to get rid
of
the the point of this is to get rid of
as much of the crap as possible. Like we
can look at the diff here. I'll show
you.
Let me sort of show you that the problem
here.
So if I just open a PR
like this is the I would never merge
this ever because it would destroy the
uh destroy the project like branch,
right? Like look at this
and you can tell this immediately.
So this has like maybe four or 500 lines
of stuff that actually matters.
Did we not get the file diff? Oh, here
you go. 5,000 [ __ ] lines for what
should be 500 lines.
You see?
So, that would double the size of Puffer
Lib's core code.
Um,
so like annoyingly this has been the
fastest way to dev on the algorithm,
but essentially all the code is
considered crap. like completely
unusable crap.
Well, I don't I didn't I don't need to
make this PR. Like, I was just doing
this to show you the line diff, right?
14 files, 5K lines changed.
It's uh
pretty cool. At least
Well, if anybody else wants to try um
Cool Ends with Puffer, I'm here to
answer questions. RL questions are
always good.
All right, that's all the RL stuff for
now, it seems.
Yeah. So, the diagnostic stuff is like
miss a total mess. Um, I have no idea
how long this thing will take, but I'm
hoping
if I can get this down to like a 500
line core diff or less, then I can also
start looking at it.
I think we do need to run some sort of a
sweep as well.
So that might be a little annoying
today. We'll see.
I'm trying to think what else we can
think about here.
Hang on. We know for sure.
We know for sure that it can work with
that little bit of domain knowledge.
Right?
If we assume that the stability comes
from hyperparameters
or the instability comes from
hyperparameters,
then it should just end up being
whatever the random solve time is
plus a little bit to latch. 25% data
used for latching.
One segment kept
The advantage thing is still bothering
me though. That's like very crucial.
Like we're not going to be able to use
this state setbased thing unless we have
a stable metric by which to admit high
quality segments.
We're currently using positive
is it some positive advantage
to be fair. I could see that right.
I mean, we are biasing it towards um
we're biasing it towards better than
expected outcome,
I guess the problem is with this
specific like this specific setup.
I mean, in some sense, this is the
trickiest possible setup, right? Like
you have to get the one important
segment into the buffer or you're
screwed.
That's the setup.
So, you don't want to ever you don't
want to kick something out
that is the lucky solve. just because
you happen to find something that's a
bad failure.
I don't know how much how this is going
to buy a set, but that seems correct to
me that you do need to keep positive
summed advant like some positive
advantage instead of summed abs
advantage.
Um it's definitely correct that you can
refine tails by reward and it's
definitely correct that you can reassess
uh the advantage
from the head.
So I mean all the parts of the algorithm
that I have in place seem reasonable.
If advantage is not a reliable metric
to admit segments then something is very
weird because it very much should be.
Okay, hang on. The other possibility
here, right?
The other possibility is that we just
have a tiny segment buffer which we do,
right? Um, so the noise is getting
amplified because a single noisy segment
screws us up.
So instead of like not ever admitting
noise, we could instead focus on making
sure that noise uh gets through the
buffer quickly and doesn't push out our
good segment.
The difficulty with this uh okay here
the difficulty with this right is that
we're only allowing the fresh
environments to publish segments.
Yeah, we're only allowing the fresh
environments to publish segments. So you
literally just get one good segment in
and then it's a very bad part of the
buffer. Okay, I think I have an idea now
of like what the overall error surface
is and why this thing is screwy.
I at least have some reasonable ideas
for sure.
I definitely have to put some effort
into that stuff.
Okay. A whole bunch of crap. We'll check
the line diffs.
I got to make that I got to make that
thing freaking easier. The CPU viz
thing.
Oh, it's nice to see new people trying
her today at least.
End of act replacement was wearing the
same return for every replace state.
What?
tail replacement was storing the same
return for every replace tail state.
That seems very bad, doesn't it? That
seems like catastrophically bad.
If this is actually true,
this is why I need a small diff to
review because otherwise the model does
stupid things. Very, very stupid things.
And um like coding via type [ __ ] into
codecs is just miserable and very dumb.
You're very close to the thing on the
left of the screen here, the little text
there. You're very very close to this.
This is my This is a
real research stream, sir.
Yeah. Yeah. But it's not even like it's
not even fun to [ __ ] on the big labs cuz
like it's too easy of a target, you
know?
If we really wanted to meme on it, we'd
go pick up the um the game series,
right? There's like an ARPG, Fable,
right? Isn't there an an ARPG by that
name?
And just play that like Fable all day on
stream. That'd be good.
This is the most I ever use
um codeex
and
I almost never hit the $100 a month sub
limit on x high. So
if you're using it more than that and
this is already like inadvisable
um I don't know what to tell you.
Almost killed me over the weekend. Yeah,
just write write more of your own code,
man. Write more of your own code
references. What's
okay?
Uhhuh.
That's fine. These are all old. I agree.
Hey, Call, welcome.
I did see one major bug fix in here. So,
we will see
if the uh the baseline is more stable.
Now,
I actually suppose
I actually don't know what would happen
with that to be honest. I don't know if
that would be enough to destabilize the
runs. It probably still is hypers. Um,
but if we just get like a reasonably
clean diff that I can start looking at,
that'll be nice.
All right. And then what we were going
to do is we were going to keep the one
bit of no domain knowledge for now and
get it to work for a 15 level solve with
a bigger train buffer. That was going to
be the thing.
I also have not completely figured out
how we're going to do segment
replacement in the buffer. Um,
guess if we just make the buffer bigger,
maybe it's fine.
We'll play with it. We have lots of
stuff to play with.
opt in yesterday used a commit that's
old to compared
15 level solve
100% some bugs you fixed since then with
no domain knowledge. Okay. So, with no
domain knowledge, um you have to be very
careful what counts as domain knowledge
because like using the using episode
reward to admit new segments is domain
knowledge because let's say you have a
PCGN where you can have uh different
episode rewards like different optimal
rewards for different episodes. It'll
fill it with easy episodes. So like it
doesn't seem like it's domain knowledge
but it actually is. Um I think similarly
I was doing one weird thing with the
terminals before that was technically
domain knowledge.
Uh do you have any like are there any
method changes that you have though?
Because if you have an actual no domain
knowledge 15 solves table. I'd like to
know what it is.
I'm currently trying to minimize the
diff here so I can like actually start
screwing with stuff.
Can we look? Do you remember what you
changed? Like was it some bug fixes? Was
it like a major algorithm shift? Was it
hypers?
I'm using a commit that's old, but I
made some changes. Do you have the
changes of your thing versus the commit
that you based it on?
Because this is still very much an
active problem and I would be happy to
look at it. Like I'm mostly just waiting
for this thing to like delete its own
[ __ ] at this
I would have used RS meets as instead of
top K.
Yeah. So I tried
I tried that as well. Um
that did help I believe. So there was a
change with terminals, the way that
terminals were being handled where I
then I needed to use sum squared instead
of root squared. And then I ablated that
out. And it actually turns out that um a
lot of the segments that were getting
dropped under root mean squared error
were better under some positive
advantage.
So I ablated like L1, L2, L in um some
uh some positive uh top 16 at like
positive. I think that the best was
like some positive over segment.
Was that the only thing you had to
change?
So the thing that I changed on the N
side, I remember I was setting terminals
on every level before and that was also
sort of getting exploited. So I changed
it so that now it's only terminals on
failure or on full solve
and that seems to have made it a little
bit harder which is a bit annoying.
At least it changes it makes it harder
to exploit the length of the segment
implicitly.
This is why I say that there's a lot of
stuff that doesn't seem like domain
knowledge that actually is.
RM not of positive advantage not all
advantage.
So some
did I try that?
You know I probably wanted to try that
and I probably didn't actually try that.
So, sum of positive. Okay, you know
what? You're actually right. I didn't
try that. Now, when you say root, are
you summing the entire segment and then
taking the root?
Because that will like that'll bias it
towards,
That biases it towards longer segments,
but I guess we're doing that anyways.
H
interesting.
I tried mean as well. Like maybe that is
a good trade-off. I don't really like
the length bias in there, but that's
actually a decent thing to try.
Man, that's actually what I wanted to
try. But I'm pretty sure that you're
right. Like I'm pretty sure that I
wanted to try that and I probably
accidentally included the negatives as
well.
So, this is about
I don't know. No, I think this is the
same speed as before. Okay. So, we'll
see how this goes.
Um,
we can try your thing as well
potentially, though. I don't know if I
want to try it on this version. This
version has a bunch of other weird
things.
We got 2 minutes level nine
kind of all over the place. When a start
position is sampled,
the priority of the segment forward is
changed.
I think before the entire segment was
Oh. Um I don't know what version this
was on. So, anything that was on like
you can't reset the advantage of just
the tail.
I realized what we're doing now for that
is half of the time we're sampling from
the head from the start state and uh if
that gets higher or if that gets higher
episode return then it replaces the
advantage
decay will naturally decay. Yeah. So, we
eliminated the decay as well in favor of
having the more accurate advantage
refresh. I think that's better.
They're just a lot of spaces that you
can like change things in here. Oh,
wait. What's happening on L10?
Uh, that's bizarre, right? We should be
latching L10.
Oh yeah, this is
How'd this get messed up?
Well, it'll have to inspect the log on
this because
that shouldn't be possible.
Oh yeah, I remember this from Kvert.
This was cool.
but we completely failed the latch
and
The crashiness of it is very odd because
it does actually go back up.
mind doing. Yeah. So that was actually
the terminal change magnifies the uh
instability quite a lot.
Uh, no they're not. There's a bull log.
Lovely.
Yeah, I think um
if I can get it stable on a min a
minimal diff, I do have some ideas on
why it's going to like why it would be
so unstable,
but we really should be able to solve it
with um so with reward-based admission,
you should only need one segment ever.
It really should just be one reward is
all you need.
And we had that before with slight
differences. This
Um, well, how fancy are the physics?
Because if the physics are fairly
simple, you can just implement that
yourself in a very short amount of C and
not have to deal with the heavy
libraries that don't run fast enough.
If you take a look at some of our ends,
like um our drone end for instance, our
drone end is just C.
Um pretty much everything is like that.
So don't reach for the heavy libraries
if you're not sure that you need them.
Yeah, but the thing is he doesn't need
he doesn't need the Moko library for six
pendulums. He has it like that cuz I
think he wants to do other stuff. Like
there's no reason that you need Majoko
just for doing pendulums.
I'm genuinely starting to question how
many days I should give this before I
just like scrap all the code and
implement it myself.
1500 [ __ ] lines. You've got to be
[ __ ] me.
Thanks for the tip. Pendulums are
better.
Yeah, it's the same one I gave I same
one I gave Yasine.
I was like, stop using whatever stupid
reward. Do this.
If we can get this at least to give us a
15 solve without reoptimizing hypers
fourth pendulum
I think was Hayden said he got Five. I
think up to five is pretty reasonable. I
haven't tried it myself, mind you.
I don't know. Maybe you can do like 10
of them. Who knows?
See, we get instability in the training
here,
and I don't understand why.
So, it's working fine.
I mean, if anything, that is the just
run a damn sweep thing.
At least seven is the goal.
I wouldn't be surprised if we get
somebody to do seven in the next couple
days.
This is just a single training run.
I I think we do kind of need to run a
sweep at this point.
Like I can try a couple of things I
suppose.
Like all but one of the latch times are
very good here, right?
Like once it gets a reward, it's
training correctly, but there's a lot of
instability
and uh presumably that's just preventing
it from getting the reward at all.
That's weird though. Like how does it
just not get any?
We'll check the entropy and stuff after.
So, oh wait, we do get right at the end
we start to get 14.
Entropy is kind of low. I suppose
Actually, let's let's go a little higher
than this. Let's go 0.25. 25. We'll do
2.5x.
I'd like to be like done with this
manual bullshitting loop thing
constantly.
Thanks for the endorsement here.
Helps.
It does help a lot.
Lots of engagement today, which is fun.
Always nice to see new people checking
it out
Yeah. Um I wouldn't be surprised if it's
like the hardest possible sim to real
thing. It could not be, you know. It
could just not be.
question mark.
Oh, we really broke [ __ ] didn't we?
All right. Yeah, that's time to run a
sweep, unfortunately.
Um
Oh, there's a timeout button. Yay.
Learn to read.
T flops
bandwidth VRAMm that's about right.
I mean there's a trade-off because you
do get a lot of stuff bandwidth bound.
Um
to be fair actually it might be
bandwidth is more important.
Yeah, you probably still are mostly
bandwidth bound. It depends on your
model size. For the very small ones,
it's going to mostly be like fast um
faster mem
Now, the fun thing about this is if
anybody was wondering why the hell I um
you know keep saying why I said like oh
yeah I switched because I was sick of
giving anthropic money. There you go.
There's your perfect example. These
people are [ __ ] batshit.
Yeah, exactly. It would literally it
would just like they literally said that
they [ __ ] the model over for the exact
thing that we're doing intentionally
because oh, we're so goody goody two
shoes. Like [ __ ] you. No, not a penny.
Yeah, sure. Go ahead. Run a test without
building.
Not great speed.
See, this is annoying because now it's
going to most likely have to find
Well, what are we going to do? Because
now it's like
We can keep this in. We can keep this
in.
Well, if this is getting taken out of
sweep, right,
I don't know, Arch. Maybe
I think I'm going to have gone insane by
Friday if this [ __ ] keeps up.
It's very annoying because I would have
like
I guess we'll treat this as an
experiment in some sense.
Like there's a point at which I consider
that maybe it would literally just be
effective to just not even touch the
models.
I actually didn't expect it to be this
bad.
Okay, let's try like this. So, this is
going to be like a um fairly restrictive
sweep, I would say.
I also I want to keep the mini batch
size fixed cuz otherwise I don't want it
to find like these tiny little updates.
Oh, wait. When did the mini batch size
go back to being this?
We do have a monitoring script
and obviously we have to deal with this
um cash. It's like this is not a fixed
task though. So you have to understand
so there is some uncertainty here like
it's it's like unclear how much of the
jank is also just from the algorithm
specification not being quite there as
well. There are a lot of potential
sources of error Here.
Okay. Hopefully this should be fine
if we just get a more stable but still
fast config on this.
I think the order of changes, right, is
going to be
let's get it working with one segment,
right?
Let's get a version of it that's stable,
storing a lot of segments
because we're going to need a lot of
segments for the real algorithm.
But that should be stable.
And then we should put the advantage
ablations at the end.
How often would you checkpoint
presumable sweeps?
Um,
so Arch, like there are a couple ways
you could do it.
You could literally just have the sweep
thing like load in all of the existing
checkpoints and just trade uh train the
model off of that. Like the log files
should contain everything that you need
in order to train the GP. Anyways,
I like I would think that instead of
making it resumable sweeps, it would be
better to just be able to point it at
existing logs. I think it should just
like train in a few seconds anyways.
Inject hypers for next sweep.
Force a few hypers and protein. Yeah. So
you have to delete stuff from the
default config at the moment which is
not great but also not terrible.
What's going on here? Why don't we have
logs?
Oh, it's just the first run. Lovely.
Super slow. Yeah, that's going to take
for absolutely ever. Um, cool. What do
we do in the meantime?
It's 2:00 p.m. I did want to do a
shorter day today,
but
the algorithm is just bothering me. It
really is.
You know, on one hand, I chose a very,
very hard problem.
I also haven't tuned the hypers in a
while. Maybe that's all it is.
Um, arch. So, the big PRs I want to
merge now are actually quite a bit of
work each,
I guess. Let me go over the sort of the
plans here and this the algorithm as a
whole. That'll be interesting for
people. How's that? Okay, you know what?
Let me let me sort of see if I can draw
out the algorithm and we can kind of go
through all the pieces. That'll be
interesting for people on stream. We've
got like 20 plus people watching at the
very least. Um, how about y'all give me
about give me 2 minutes to use a
restroom, walk around, and then we will
diagram out the new algorithm and we can
discuss like potential changes to it and
you all can sort of see where this is
going.
Of course, I wash my hands. You think
I'm a [ __ ] animal?
Stupid convert.
I'll be right back.
Okay,
I'm going to go over the algorithm.
I think this will be useful, right?
So,
I've kind of been staring at this thing
for a while. Hopefully I can speak in
reasonable complete sentences here. When
I've been Devon for a while,
I kind of just get all into symbols and
logic mode.
Okay, let's let's go over the algorithm.
So, uh I'm going to just get something
to draw on.
So here's the the uh the design.
Currently,
you have some fraction of states in your
buffer.
They're allocated to curriculum.
So, this is horizon.
Why don't I just use the text tool like
not an idiot?
This is horizon.
And then this is
let's do like let's put it here. This is
ends.
now I remember why I didn't use the
[ __ ] text tool.
All right.
Decrease sweep ranges
and learning rate. No, you can't
decrease horizon. Horizon turns out to
be very important. Um,
I did make it I did reduce the potential
of it to try to cl crank up data ratios
though. So it can't find any really slow
configs under the current version. Okay.
So this is the number of M's. This is
the horizon. This is our standard
rollout buffer. Right?
Uh now what we do is we divide these
into
I should make this one smaller.
These are CLMs curriculum MS.
And then these ones are fresh.
You can kind of like you know divide
like this. So you have some number of
environments that are going to be uh
always getting fresh data. These are
basically the same as in puffer 4. So in
puffer 5 we're going to have some
fraction that are devoted to curriculum.
Now for these curriculum ends
you have this additional buffer.
And I think we should even make it
smaller. Yeah, let's make it smaller.
I'm not using the text tool. Text tools
is annoying. So, this is horizon
and uh this is going to be
the buffer size. So you know state
buffer
and this door is whole segments. I
should probably call it segment buffer.
Right?
So
when you sample
uh when you sample MS like this
horizon is how many ticks it watches.
Yes.
So the idea is you do your roll out
and actually here I can use the text
tool.
Um,
yeah, we can use the text tool here
because it's going to be like one
collects
store highest
advantage highest
positive sum advantage segments.
in buffer.
Why did this change to black?
That's really annoying. Why would you
ever do that?
cuz it's like, oh, it's misspelled.
That's really stupid. Whatever. Uh, CLN
sample
Is this actually unusable? The stupid
tool. Hang on.
Uh, line width, word spacing.
Is there literally no text option?
Oh, okay. There it is. It's just it's
while you're typing is shitty. That's
fine.
Let's see if this covers. Let's see how
much this covers. Right,
Let me think what what can we use for um
what other visuals do we need? So store
top k highest positive sum advantage
segments in buffer.
You know the thing that's probably
getting messed up here.
This was supposed to be a rolling
window.
Yeah, I got to I obviously have to make
this clearer now.
Yeah. Cuz right now, so the way that
this works, right, is you have these
ends
go into the buffer
and then samples
go into here.
So the fresh environment store data to
this buffer. This buffer stores the top
k highest positive sum advantage
segments.
Yeah, that is an issue. Arch. So, that
was what I was thinking about right now.
It's supposed to be the last end states.
There's also no reason that this needs
to be of length horizon, right?
Okay. Um,
let's revise this a little bit. Okay.
Let's revise this a little bit.
Where's the eraser on this thing?
Just like
Yeah, let's let's let's revise this a
little bit.
Let's say that this is going to be like
a different size buffer. So, we'll make
it an obviously different size.
And then this is going to be the
Then this is segments.
And let's actually make it even a little
clearer. So we don't need to store every
single one of these. So the way that
this would work is
This is annoying because you would need
an intermediate buffer, right?
Update sword priority if new. Yeah.
States per segment greater than equal to
horizon. Well, it could be greater, it
could be less.
So the thing that I'm trying to think
here now is you know if you start if you
get the high advantage at the start you
need to restore you have to have the
previous one stored.
Oh you know what I remember how this
worked. Okay.
So,
can we calculate advantage forward? You
can't calculate advantage forward.
Right?
It's supposed to be like this is where
you get your high advantage state.
You have some state stored here. Maybe
it goes backwards through time.
So it's like this.
This is already stored. So this one is
here.
How do we handle how do we handle the
segment bounds?
Yeah,
if I thought this was clever, but this
is flirting with off policy.
If we're going to store by advantage,
it's flirting with off policy. Okay, see
this is good that I did this cuz I'm
starting to see some little like some
little problems here and there. Um the
simple version of the algorithm like
very very close is what I say here which
is just the top k pos highest positive
some advantage segments go into the
buffer
I think you have to have states per
segment greater than equal than horizon.
And it's actually it's easier if it's
less than the horizon, frankly. So
here's the issue, right? Like let's take
a segment.
So this is like the ideal segment,
right?
Right here. This is where you get your
reward
R equals 1, right? And then your peak
advantage
um is going to be what? like one step
before it or whatever depending how you
have it aligned
or on it.
So this is like
your ideal segment.
So what you're going to say is
yeah advantage peak like
advantage max
is right here.
Now, you'd like like it's easy to say,
oh, you just store high advantage
states, then this goes into the buffer,
right? But this is actually bad because
this only lets you learn one step. What
you actually need to do, and this is why
we're storing segments, not just states,
is you actually need to store all these
states. Or at the very least, you know,
you can downsample them and you can
store this state here, this state here,
and like this state here.
And these can go into your buffer
like this.
That's allowed.
Now the tricky thing I think as you
implied arch. So this is ideal.
This is like we don't have to think this
works. Now the tricky thing is uh and
I'm using like obviously you can have
high advantage without having the
reward. I'm using this as the initial
case of you discover a new a new level
solver a new high reward right so
the case that you're that you're
concerned with is this
Now there is a trick that we can do
which is this buffer still has data from
the last episode or the last um yeah the
last epoch right? This still has data.
So what we can do is we could loop back
around
to here and grab like this date, this
date, right?
We can do this.
So then actually the thing that makes
the most sense in my head
is that we should make this
this is going to be
horizon. is in
date check
frequency,
right?
Cuz we just go backwards
Now, okay, the question is how do we
detect that we have high advantage?
Cuz don't we have to rerun the
computation on everything.
I think we do have to rerun the
computation which is not ideal.
Hang on. Does this make sense
on a MacBook? M4 MacBook. Um,
you can use it. You're not going to get
the very good PF out of it, though. I
will say that you can literally if you
want to like run this on a cheap Nvidia
GPU, you can rent decent ones for 10
cents an hour on vast. So it's very
cheap.
Uh, I don't know if that's entirely
true, but there might be some stuff
that's specifically designed for Mac.
Um,
but like realistically, you should just
be running it on an Nvidia GPU.
Can anybody figure out if this is
reasonable? So what I basically want is
I want an advantage estimate not using
obviously like the advantage estimate is
not going to be the correct one using
the future rewards but like can you
compute a given that this is the final
step based on a t minus one.
Well it's not right. Look, it says,
"Wait, no, that's wrong. That's wrong.
H. No, it's not going to be correct.
It's going to give me [ __ ] isn't
it?
[ __ ]
That actually matters.
I mean, we can do it the slow way first
to be fair.
It looks to me like there's got to be
some sort of rearrangement. No.
TD first date plus TD last date.
What last state though?
Wait, is this are you giving me this?
Because this one is for this one is for
lambda equals zero only
you know
I mean we can do it the slow way first
and then we can be sure it's not wrong.
So here
but then wait it's highest positive sum
advantage segments.
What you want is like you do want the
advantage, but you want the advantage.
I guess it is. I guess it is. You just
want to handle the boundaries. I think
this description is still correct. And
then the detail is that we have to go
backwards through them.
How do you populate the CL if you don't
have the whole you do have the whole
horizon arch? So the trick here is that
um the end like the states that you need
previous like if you get it at the start
the states are still in the buffer here.
So actually that's not going to be true
for the curriculum ends which is a
problem.
Crap.
Well, see that's difficult because
advantage peaks.
Well, at the very least, I'm seeing lots
of places here where there are like
small details that end up that could
very much end up screwing things up.
It does make it a lot easier if we just
assume an intermediate buffer, right? We
still have to run the advantage calcs
all the damn time.
segment buffer storing advantages.
Uh it's storing the states
and then it's storing the currently it's
storing the sum of advantages over the
segment that we store.
All right, let's actually freaking think
here. This is important to figure out
how we do this. So,
the core idea
is that when you get a high advantage
state, right,
you need to also store the stuff that
came before it
because otherwise you're going to end up
resetting to like right before the
reward and you're not actually going to
be able to expand backwards in time.
Yeah. So that's the big issue, right? Is
that if you like if you get a lucky
reward for instance,
the states that are back 16 32 steps are
going to be fairly low advantage at
first.
You also it's the wrong model to think
of high advantage states as well cuz
that implies like a single spike. You do
want the high advant like summed
advantage.
Yes. Is there an issue with instead per
segment double the length and sort t?
The thing that's tricky about this,
right? So,
the thing that's tricky about this is if
you're given some sort of puzzle, right?
And um you get a solve trajectory,
like let's say you have a hard puzzle.
I'm going to use the mazes for this,
even though the mazes aren't that hard.
Like this, right?
Um, the highest advantage states,
the highest advantage states are going
to be like right here.
Or actually, I guess we can draw it like
this with like high advantage,
right? It gets lower as you go further
back.
cuz you don't want to store like the
whole episodes or anything. That's nuts,
right?
3D picking of rollouts
focused.
Well,
we're exploring a bunch of different
ways of potentially doing stuff here.
3D picking. Did you ask me about this
with the state set stuff specifically?
Um,
you can't pick rollouts by you cannot
select among rollouts by reward
is the main issue. Oh,
Oh, that Yeah.
Um, it's not so much that the
it's not so much that the LLM's like
that the algorithm like they're being
stupid by using the algorithm. The the
clear statement of that is that the
algorithms that LLM people are forced to
use because of the con like the
constraints of their problem are much
weaker than the RL algorithms we have
access Tell
it on the agent.
That that doesn't make sense in this
context.
Yeah, episode reward. So, it's it's
naive. It'll look very good on specific
tasks. I'm trying to think what the the
version of this that makes sense is. Um,
if we think of this as just having one
trajectory that we're refining,
Of course, storing the entire episode is
like insane.
Let's say if I could store the entire
episode, how would I do it? Um,
well, in this case, it's a deterministic
end, so you only need one episode.
You just store whatever the hell the
highest return thing is, cuz there's
only one of them.
You probably sample it.
somewhere around the highest advantage.
Okay. And then if you have multiple of
these
Man, this is I don't know. I'm off
today. Like, I'm confused.
There many different ways you could
implement stuff.
All the go explore things kind of they
act like they're
kind of just optimizing the trajectories
is what they're doing.
Yeah, I was thinking of this as
optimizing segments.
If anybody wants to go figure out what
the guy in the Discord is doing, is
somebody in general, I want to open it
on stream,
It's like surprisingly complicated here.
So,
guess what's the simple version of this?
You just try to find some good
trajectories. Is that what it is?
doing it by advantage is kind of like
advantage does tell you the it gives you
the correct signal for the next step but
then it's too myopic.
Also, the head sampling thing to refresh
advantage is very difficult cuz that
requires you to solve the whole thing.
Check DMs.
Uh, hang on.
sample from here to put into CL buffer.
Yeah, I can show this, right? So,
So on the free ones, you can get that
implicitly without even needing the
extra storage buffer. And that is part
of the problem, but that's not the
entire problem.
Like yeah, that is that's a good
diagram. Like you have a good
understanding of that chunk of it.
Do you mind explaining what I'm missing?
I would love to. Um,
but I have myself all confused at the
moment. So, let me see what it's going
to take me to get my thoughts straight
on this. Um,
there's several competing issues here.
Okay. So,
what you're saying is you store from the
current point, you calculate the
advantage,
then you store the last end states.
Sure.
I've had versions of that as well.
Maybe that is enough.
I guess
how much evidence do we want to assign
to
the experience so far that waiting by
advantage seems noisy.
like us waiting what stuff we put into
the buffer by what has higher advantage.
That seems very noisy.
That's a big problem at the moment.
The closer to go explore thing would be
to do it to just basically have some
segments or have some trajectories
and we optimize those
Yeah. So, Arch, the alternative, and
this is now what I'm considering. Okay.
So the alternative would be
uh that we just set up some ends to be
curriculum ends
and those have their seed or whatever
and then instead of looking for like new
high advantage segments we just want to
optimize the reward for those end
rollouts.
So in the case of
in the case of this game it would be
that we keep a single segment because
it's a deterministic N. Um any like
deterministic single seed end should
only need one segment
or one episode.
And anytime we get higher reward, higher
episode return,
we overwrite the tail of the segment or
we overwrite, you know. Yeah, we
overwrite the tail of the segment with
the highest episode reward uh return
thing. That is still general.
And then the only thing we would have to
figure out is the within the within
segment sampling
which could be literally anything. The
within segment sampling could be
literally anything.
The problem with this is having to keep
um
Yeah, the problem with this is having to
keep
whole episodes or at least like somewhat
downsampled episodes
around.
How do you replace the head and go back
in time? Yeah, exactly. Um, so your
thing is correct, Arch. Like your your
thing fixes that locally for the
segment. Um, but we still have the issue
of how do we like how do we choose which
segments to admit into the buffer and
how do we choose what to kick out of the
buffer? That's been the main issue at
the moment.
We can still use advantage
if we have a fixed.
I think I have to rethink quite a bit of
stuff on this algorithm to be honest.
This is good. Okay, this section here.
What? This is good. This is good.
This is questionable.
Wait, no. Can't you replace
You can replace Tails with it for
advantage.
H.
Can't you sample by waiting? Yeah, I
tried that. That doesn't work
max number of states potentially grows a
lot.
how do you do three without storing the
entire episode.
No, three you can do like three you just
need to know the episode return up to
the start point
and then if you get higher essentially
you get higher discounted return in this
new segment than in the previous segment
you're fine.
The storing entire episodes thing is
like a feels bad man for me though.
segments don't overlap.
Uh you can assume that if you want, I
guess
this is more irritating than expected.
Definitely more irritating than
expected.
I think I'm going to give it like 20
minutes. This might be like an Well, I'm
trying to think if this is like an end
stream early and go take a long walk
angle, honestly.
Like we've definitely learned quite a
bit of stuff.
If changes made are good,
uh, we should just have the god
algorithm. Of course,
commit. Uh, there aren't really any good
changes yet. Kvert
How's progress? Pretty confusing,
honestly. We've learned a lot of stuff.
I'm not sure I like there are a bunch of
failure points in the current algorithm
that make me want to rethink a few
things with it.
It's also a little bit concerning to me
that like
Yeah, it's the state curriculum stuff.
I think the states having ways to find
Yeah. So that is that is um let's say
that we're planning this around the idea
that that will pair very nicely, but
that on its own is not enough.
downgrading every T over two states.
My advantage isn't at the tail end.
Well, I can do that arch, but it's
pretty hacky.
How certain there was positive the
result has been. So the thing is that
the thing that we're certain about is
that we can integrate state setable
simulator state to like magnificent
effect. That is not in question. Like
there's strong enough evidence that it's
basically impossible that that's wrong,
right? Um the thing that we're less sure
about is the exact form that it should
take.
What's up with storing whole episodes?
It's kind of janky, Finn. That' be a lot
of mem.
And so you have exams in like what? Two
weeks less.
Start thinking about what stuff you want
to work on, though. You can pretty much
work on whatever.
There was this other paper. Where was
it?
Where was the other crazy paper?
thing is I don't know if I trust it yet.
Was let me find the name of it.
Um
Revisit the diagram particularly the
worst case. This is the worst case here.
This is not that big of an issue. Um,
this is solved by the thing that Arch
sent, which is just like store the last
n states. Um, and I actually even had
that at some point. That doesn't solve
the full issue.
Let me check with this real quick.
I actually don't know. Um
I don't know if this comparison is fair.
The sample failure like sample
comparison is fair at
I'm not really thinking about using this
as much as I'm just thinking about what
it implies.
Any fraction of an entire episode?
Well, I'm considering that arch.
Uh yeah, Tim, I'm just sick of dealing
with it.
Save a checkpoint for today and dinner.
Not dinner time yet, though. I am
getting kind of tired. I would I would
not mind taking a walk for a bit.
I think with the temperature outside.
It's okay though. We can think a little
bit.
I just I have too many tradeoffs in my
head at the moment.
And like I have several pieces of
uncertain information that I'm trying to
like put against each other to assign
relative confidence to and it's just too
touch
like okay the idea of storing states is
very Nice.
actually, did I come up with a setting
where go explore gets screwed?
No, because they have the uncertainty
measure, right?
Let me think what happens if I
reformulated around that entirely.
found out a puff we're looking forward
to using. Thank you and welcome.
I'm currently stuck on a hard bit of
algorithm dev.
I guess another question would be where
can we use advantage? That would narrow
it down, right?
Where can we actually use advantage
because having stuff just based on
uncertainty is not good. The uncertainty
measures that people use suck anyways
does tell you how powerful they are.
We actually have a very very good
measure of um
like where you need to learn stuff. But
the problem is it's like um it's like a
water balloon. You know, you poke it in
one place and it moved somewhere else
and then oops, you didn't store that
Hey,
How do they like maintain their
trajectories as Oh,
Okay. So, you have states and
trajectories.
Okay.
Yeah, I see this and I see how this was
improved over.
Um, I think that the key here, Techno,
is you need setable simulator state to
make it tractable. You completely need
setable simulator state.
For anybody who's new around here, um,
take a moment to start puffer on GitHub,
please. It's a lot of work and it really
does help us out a ton. Oh, 5.9K.
Thank you for all the new stars.
It does help us out a lot. Um, all our
stuff's free and open source. Uh, Puffer
is a company though. The way we make
money is by building ultra high
performance simulations
uh for a variety of domains for
companies.
Yeah. Okay.
Go explore is a very simple algorithm.
It makes sense.
This is basically tree searchy go
explore right
using R&D instead of cell
representations.
Yeah, I need to read this paper more, I
think.
You can't just have one set of states
per end though, can you
Failure is inevitable regardless of the
policy.
Okay.
State lineage tree
a tree search method decoupling
exploration. Okay.
I cumulative reward and epistemic
uncertainty.
by cloning winners and removing dead
particles.
Every particle interacts with its own
instance of the environment
agnostic to
mechanism.
This is very fast because it's a random
actions.
Okay.
Winner selection and particle
redistribution
redistribute computational effort by
identifying winners.
All dead particles are set to the winner
state.
allows the groups to share a centralized
uncertainty estimator.
This doesn't give you any
robustification, right?
This is going to produce like awful,
shitty, terribly long trajectories,
right?
Oh, wait. I think this is not
comparable, is it?
I think the thing I'm not certain about
is I think that go explore is counting
the frames to return to states and this
one isn't.
Interesting.
Okay, we'll have to figure that one out.
But um
Well, does this tell us anything?
Not really. It just tells us that okay,
tree search is better than random
search.
Uh I don't think anybody would know
that.
I I don't think that it's particularly
easy to know either way.
Buffer help understand RL.
Pretty versed in RL theory. No, you're
not meant to have a bunch of RL theory.
And a bunch of our contributors came in
with no experience.
Um, actually, the way I do stuff,
having a bit of low-level engineering
background is much more helpful than
having a bunch of theory. If you're new
to the space, these two articles are for
you.
Uh this one for RL in particular, this
will get you into
into RL by doing stuff and filling in
gaps in knowledge slowly over time.
It's not like Hufferlib was not designed
as an educational library. It just turns
out that the way that I do stuff ended
up um being really really useful for
getting people into the space, which is
now which is why we now have I think the
biggest open-source
uh contributor pool for an RL project
out there.
Why can't we seem to rail it? You might
be able to bet. I don't know. I just I
foresee one thing that could go very
wrong with it.
Let me use a restroom real quick. We'll
come up with some thoughts and we'll see
if we have anything else we can do on
this today.
uncertainty, huh?
Novelty and uncertainty are a little bit
different.
Uh,
no, they're kind of similar, actually.
They're kind of similar.
the two educational articles. I mean,
all the other articles, frankly, right,
are on cutting edge research, but
they're a heck of a lot more accessible
than you'd find most papers to be.
Like they're for a variety of different
audience levels.
If you do the if you follow the guide,
you'll be able to read the other ones.
as a trajectory optimization problem,
I'm not saying we are.
The fact they're storing a tree is
really obnoxious, isn't it?
Yeah, cuz the thing is
they're kind of two different
objectives.
Yeah, you can't store. Okay, the problem
is like
you need to store the episode,
but just storing the best episode is not
enough.
And then you want to do this across a
bunch of different ends.
which funny enough I would think their
algorithm would suck that
Yep. That's the funny one
game.
I'm trying to think if I should just go
take a walk with this.
Yeah.
Let me check what the temperature is
outside.
it's nice. 73 degrees.
Yeah, I'm thinking that I should just
call it early today and go like walk and
think because
I basically there's just there too many
competing things going around in my head
right now to even get this straight. Um
cuz like the uncertainty thing, right? I
was hoping that we were I guess let me
give a little overview as to why I've
been so confused for the last hour or
two. So the uncertainty thing is what I
was hoping we could look at as a
separate optimization
uh that we could then plug into whatever
I come up with on 50 to solve a
different type of problem. But uh right
now the go explore line of algorithms
are treating that as core. I thought we
were going to be able to slot in
advantage as just a replacement for
that, but advantage seems like it's a
little bit tricky because um high
advantage segments
uh are not like that's not where you
need to learn because as soon as you
learn the high advantage state,
advantage shifts back earlier, which
that's not how it works with
uncertainty. Uncertainty is the other
way, right? You learn uncertainty as
you're going and then the next time you
get more uncertainty, you keep going.
So, it's kind of different.
So,
I kind of need to just get all this
stuff straight in my head and see to
what extent we can just do something
based off of advantage and to what uh
extent uncertainty would have to be
fundamentally integrated to do anything
with setible state. That's like the key
thing that doesn't click at the moment.
So, yeah, I think I just got to go take
a walk and figure this out. I know we've
got like 20 people watching, but I've
been live for 4 hours and I'm stuck. So,
I don't think it's productive for me to
just sit here for the rest of the day
and be boring. Um,
yeah. I'm going to just go think about
this stuff for a bit and uh get some
fresh air, see what where that goes. So,
for anybody that's new around here, my
stuff's all at puffer.ai.
It's all open source. If you want to
help us out for absolutely free, star
puffer on GitHub. We're almost at 6K. If
you want to get involved with
development, most of which is much
easier and a lot less painful than the
algo dev side that you're seeing here.
Discord's right here. And other than
that, you can follow me on X for more RL
content, including educational stuff and
uh cutting edge. Thank you.